As the glacial ice receded over 35,000 years ago, there appeared for the first time Cro-Magnon, or Modern Man.
Chances are slim that he descended from Neanderthal Man since the two lived side-by-side for 5,000 years.
Cousin or conqueror, Cro-Magnon Man did win out in the end.
Here we are, standard model.
The grouchy model.
Not much can be done to improve that.
Well, yes, there is something.
Our next model, indestructible.
Not to mention the sleeker model.
No, no, not like that.
Like that.
Here's not too swift.
If we don't move with the herd, there'll be nothing to eat.
You'll see.
Oh, yes.
Oh, you and your hunting.
We'll eat just the same.
Get one thing straight.
Take the big animals, you get the little beasties.
Okay with you?
It's okay.
Get along with the weapons they've got in their belts, Chief.
Some pretty nice stuff you've got there.
Could we look at them?
Take a look, sure.
Feel the blade.
Hmm, real nice.
And that thing, what's that?
Look for yourself.
When you say we make a switch, eh?
Come up here.
How about two mammoth skins, all right?
Is that agreed?
Nope.
How about two more and some tusks?
Take it, Pierre. It's a good deal.
Then here are the tools.
Let's have a class of luck.
Yeah.
Them too.
Here you are.
All right, men.
Right here.
Then we're looking at the first wall, imagine.
To work.
About the same tools.
Whoa, too little idiot.
This is how it's done.
Easy.
You quicks.
Get to work.
Not an idea.
That is over. The animal is dismembered.
Panning, the leftover hides will be used for clothing.
Horns became tools, as well as ornaments.
It makes sturdy shovels, and from the bones ground to a fine powder, Maestro concocts something mysterious.
They're these outlandish gadgets.
Boy, at least with this you might catch something.
Gee, thanks.
I want to catch stuff with this.
Watch out, Pierrette.
Water.
With this dirt, we can paint the faces of our hunting heroes, our companions, our chieftains.
We can cover the walls with artwork, hides, too, and clothing.
Very interesting.
It can be used for much more, too.
We have some of that page stuff.
Mm-hmm.
You're getting low, and I just missed getting a hair as big as this.
A morph and a chipmunk.
Big as this.
We're gonna need at least two tribes worth of men to bring it up, all right?
Okay.
Hooray, hooray, hooray.
See you then tomorrow at dawn.
See you then.
They're in the gorge.
Watch out.
There they are.
The beast first, you know that's true.
Okay, okay.
Welcome to join our feast.
Join up with our...
Hey.
Bravo.
Good idea.
First, you add a little salt and pepper of bouquet garni, simmer slowly, and don't forget to bash it from time to time.
The next day, the tribes bundled up and set out towards more clement skies.
Where there were two tribes, now there is one.
That is hope against hope, that they'll get along well together.
Some more about this, you three.
You weights, you weights, you bunch of...
There, yeah, you fatty, step right up here and I'll...
So I'm waiting for you, come on, tubs, I'm waiting for you to get along to see...
Paso, you got it straight, got my drift, you got it?
This can't stand in the way of progress.
Wise maestro proceeds to the initiation of the tribe's young hunters.
Boys think you're gonna get off this easy the next time around
Seasons pass our venerable maestro has devised a calendar to mark the passage of time enough one fine day
It's spring again. Walk walk walk
Just you wait till I've got an idea come here the large beasts of God the little ones outrun even our fastest hunters
So then if you want to have enough food, I have a proposal to me. Well, why not excellent idea?
Micah get away with this what's what's the matter dear?
"My dear sir, that is the situation. If you'd be kind enough to follow me, I would be much obliged."
"Oh, how nice! My word, how lovely! Didn't you make it yourself?"
Now 10,000 years before our modern era, man has already been through more than 99% of his historical development.
Population has grown from 125,000 to 10 million.
But has man reached maturity? If not, how long will it take him?